[Music]
ad astra sorry I couldn't think of
anything for the beginning so we just
kind of went right to title so ad Astros
movie starring Brad Pitt it premiered at
Toronto International Film Festival I
believe I know it was shown there I
wasn't there still haven't seen Joker
and critics are raving about this thing
this you would swear to God every critic
got married to this thing in Toronto
which makes sense the movie comes across
as a little pretentious sometimes I go
through the movies bad or anything like
that it's not bad it just kind of comes
across a bit like two or two fools
sometimes the story is Brad Pitt's an
astronaut he's a bit of a legacy child
because his father played by Tommy Lee
Jones he was on an expedition that went
to Neptune's that he get away from the
Sun so that he'd get clearer images of
other planets because they want to look
for intelligent life his father
disappeared some 30 years ago so now
Brad Pitt needs to go to Neptune in a
nutshell also just gonna address the
fact that this movie has two out of four
space cowboys in it and that ain't bad
you're gonna get right into the thing
like the common denominator the binder
the thing that everyone really agrees on
about this movie and that is it looks
gorgeous
it's competently shot it's like watching
a painting that moves and that is this
movie the movies it looks beautiful but
this is it and you have to know this so
lock in right here this is the thing you
need to take away from this review if
nothing else this is it
this movie is a slow burn if that's not
your thing this movie's not your thing
because slow burn is what I would use to
describe it other than you know looks
gorgeous looks gorgeous slow burn a
gorgeous looking slow burn slow burn in
terms of pacing and Brad Pitt having two
pages of dialogue it's a bit hyperbolic
he probably has more than that but I
really feel like his role was written
for Ryan Gosling like if someone told me
I don't know at all but if someone said
hey the story goes it was written for
Ryan Gosling and then Ryan Gosling was
like dude I'm already Neil Armstrong I
don't want to do this twice I would not
be the least bit surprised this role is
very Ryan Gosling
esque which makes sense for his betrayal
of Neil Armstrong because astronauts
that keep their cool Brad Pitt's one of
those guys is like his pulse rate never
raises to sell the stuff you heard about
Ryan Gosling in first man or Neil
Armstrong in general with that slow burn
element there are definitely
tastes this little hints of Cooper akin
here it might be because I just watched
2001 a Space Odyssey look a couple of
weeks ago but I really feel like there
are some Stanley Kubrick 2001 Space
Odyssey influences in this movie which
doesn't surprise me because there are
2001 Space Odyssey influences and a lot
of sci-fi movies but that's how
influential 2001 a Space Odyssey was
it's so influential in fact so well shot
it spawned a moon landing conspiracy who
else can say that that's his jam it's
the pocket he's keeping it in and you
have to know that because if that's not
your thing this won't be your thing
that's what I'm here for here to inform
you in fact when I got out of this movie
in the movie screenings or someone with
the clipboard they're all like alright
what do you think and you give them your
one-line consensus of what you thought
from of the movie that just ended 10
seconds ago I just said I don't know ask
me in a couple days I actually saw this
movie five days ago so I just wanted to
give it time to marinate be like alright
let me process I've seen a few people
say this is the most accurate movie
involving space travel and that's
probably true because there's a lot of
down time and that's how space travel
would be it's not exciting you're kind
of sitting there it's kind of like if
there was a movie about a lot of people
doing paperwork at desks for two hours
I'd be like that's the most accurate
movie about a police officers life
because a lot of paperwork and I would
say there's downtime in this movie but
it feels like downtime when you're
watching it but really that they are
character moments it's there to draw the
scene out and draw out the emotion and
be with Brad Pitt's character and that's
part of Brad Pitt's character as part of
his arc like you do see him grow as the
movie goes on there's this one scene
where someone's talking with him and you
see the emotion in his face and very few
actors can have so few lines yet still
show you yeah I'm the [ __ ] man and
this is my acting talent this is my
prowess and that's why I'm the [ __ ] Brad
Pitt's one of those guys and just in
case you don't connect with this
emotionally closed off fast or not which
by definition it's harder to do because
he has emotionally closed off a
connection usually comes with emotion or
empathizing with someone's display of
emotion point is if it's difficult don't
worry
you have voiceover in this movie and at
first when I came out of the movie I was
like the voiceover might have been
overcooking it a bit but if I really
step back and think about this movie
with
out any Brad Pitt voiceover this movie
probably would have lost me not taking
away anything about what I said but the
emotion in his face and his good acting
but that's an arc that's like near the
end of the movie until it happens the
voice-over is how you connected all with
this emotionless person the voice-over
probably saves the movie so as much as
you might think and why'd they have it
it's necessary boy so fer can work
dexter voice-over is probably the best
use of it casinos like 75% voiceover and
that movie rocks the message about
humanity in the end I wasn't I was like
okay that's when the movies less special
because it's the visuals that's the
unique part that's what stands out to me
the little message at the end I I've
heard that a few times before it's one
of those rare cases whereas high on
itself as this movie felt like it was I
can't say the movies bad like it's well
done and I'll say it was a good time no
alcohol required this shirt ripping your
eyes out just notice it has a bit of a
pattern I'm not refilling this thing so
if it did I'm sorry
alright so ad astra have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your favorite space odyssey movie you
can pick from any of them whatever it is
whatever you think I meant below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you